here's a riddle for you Anna's mother
has four daughters the eldest was named
April the second one is May and the next
is June what's the name of the last
daughter the answer of course is Anna
but if you answer July it doesn't mean
that you're incapable of intelligent
reasoning it's just that you've let your
judgment be clouded relying on the gist
of a statement instead of focusing on
the details can lead intelligent people
to make poor decisions another reason
smart people some times end up doing
stupid things is the so-called expert
bias after years of experience in a job
we begin to act on autopilot which can
mean we miss critical information
there's also such thing as the too much
talent effect this happens when each
member of a team is out to prove that
they are the smartest person in the room
research has shown that problem solving
skills in creativity are reduced when we
feel we're in competition with others